so how do you wrap your head around
what's happening I mean you were engaged
you broke up I mean that's got to be
emotionally draining for you I mean so
why'd you decide to do another reality
show I think this is a great way to have
a fresh start I am much more than just
who my partner is in life and being
connected to a man and I want people to
know that there's much more to the story
of Hannah Brown and being able to do
this show is a great way to show that
with the world how did you know how are
you overcoming all those headlines and
you know the disconnect with
Bachelorette I think it's just trying to
focus on other things and what's next
for me and coming to terms with I'm
about to be in a dance studio for eight
hours a day and trying to get moved in
to my new apartment in Los Angeles when
I just moved across the country from
Alabama kind of takes up a lot of my
time so not really to focus on the
headlines that I'm in and yeah so that's
that's taking up a lot of time trying to
move and get prepared and start this new
life are you concerned about anybody any
of the competition I mean you have Ray
Lewis you have all these you know these
athletes I think the competition's gonna
be really stiff this year I think it's
going to be a good group celebs but I'm
not I've got something to offer and got
some moves but I can't really focus on
competing against the other people I
just when we continue to get better and
better each week for myself and that's
all that I can really of me any moves
you mentioned moves every news you can
share with us or tell us about ourselves
I'm keeping this in my back pocket I
really I I mean how could she have
everyone there's no pockets of the dress
like a chevron well the one I don't know
if I can show but I can just tell you
that my head and talent is I can
actually twerk pretty pretty good but I
can't in this dress it that's it's not
appropriate but I can but maybe on the
show we might get we might get to see a
little if they buy some Liz oh it just
happens it just happens it was I come
fine